Speaker 1: Many of you expressed a great interest
and and enjoyment from what's going on between
Elon Musk and the MAGA people and Donald Trump.
And there's another crazy layer to this story,
which is that Donald Trump spent the afternoon
yesterday on Truth Social, also known as truth
essential to Donald Trump attacking Elon Musk.
And this is one of the funniest.
It's sort of like a like a relationship gone
bad.
They're now estranged lovers of sorts.
So let me give you the backstory on what's
going on.
When Elon Musk announced he's going to buy
Twitter and he's going to bring back free
speech or whatever, non-essential.
And Musk said the right and the MAGA right
locked back to Twitter and they flocked to
Elon Musk as their savior.
He's going to return our voice and we're no
longer going to be discriminated against for
being a transphobic or what.
Yeah, whatever they wanted to do.
Then Elon Musk was even further ingratiated
with these right wingers when he started saying,
I am now, although I've never voted for Republicans
before, I'm going to start voting for Republicans.
I am now going.
I'm still a moderate, but I'm going to start
voting for Republicans because I believe they're
better than Democrats in what they offer.
And the MAGA crowd absolutely loved it.
But then things went sour and the first thing
that happened is that Elon Musk said, I'm
actually not going to buy Twitter.
And over the weekend, during his Anchorage,
Alaska rally, Donald Trump said, Elon Musk
told me that he voted for me.
But then later he said, I've never voted for
Republicans before.
Elon Musk, a report responded to that report
on Twitter and said not true, saying Trump
is lying, saying, I never told Donald Trump
that.
I told him that I voted for him.
And then at the very same Anchorage rally,
Donald Trump started going after Elon Musk
in a more significant way.
Speaker 3: Another one of our highest priorities
under a Republican Congress will be to stop
left wing censorship and to restore free speech
in America.
And go out, by the way, while I'm here and
sign up now for Truth Social.
It's hot as a pistol.
And you see that?
I pulled that one, right, Leon?
I tell you what, Ellen.
Ellen, right.
He's not going to by Twitter.
Where did you hear that before?
From me, from a fake account.
She says a lot of them know he's got himself
a mess.
You know, he said the other day, oh, I've
never voted for a Republican.
I said, I didn't know that.
He told me voted for me.
So he's another Bush, but he's not going to
be by.
And not going to be buying it, although he
might later.
Who the hell knows what's going to happen?
He's got a pretty rotten contract.
I looked at his contract.
Not a good contract.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
Unclear how Trump got a hold of that contract.
But anyway, so Elon Musk responded to that
as well.
And he said, listen, this is a quote from
Elon Musk, I don't hate the man, but it's
time for Trump to hang up his hat and sail
into the sunset.
Democrats should also call off the attack.
Don't make it so that Trump's only way to
survive is to regain the presidency.
So Musk turning on Trump, the MAGA, Twitter,
people going bonkers and then Trump just absolutely
erupts.
Yesterday, untruth, social spending the afternoon
ranting and raving about Elon Musk saying,
quote, When Elon Musk came to the White House
asking me for help on all of his many subsidized
projects, whether it's electric cars that
don't drive long enough, by the way.
I mean, you know, praise or criticize Musk
for whatever you want.
But the range on Tesla's is at the top of
electric vehicles.
Okay?
Electric cars that don't drive long enough,
driverless cars that crash or rocket ships
to nowhere, without which subsidies he'd be
worthless.
And telling me how he was a big Trump fan
and Republican.
I could have said, Drop to your knees and
beg and he would have done it.
Now Elon should focus on getting himself out
of the Twitter mess because he could oh, $44
billion for something that's perhaps worthless.
Also lots of competition for electric cars.
P.S.
Why was Elon allowed to break the $15 million
stock purchase barrier on Twitter without
any reporting?
That is a very serious breach.
Have fun, Elon and Jack, go to it now.
Funny that Trump tags Jack Dorsey, but that's
Jack Dorsey's on Twitter.
He's not on truth social as far as I could
tell.
Look it out quickly.
Elon Musk went from right wing savior to right
wing enemy just because he said, I'm not buying
Twitter.
I never told Trump I voted for him.
And Trump should move on from politics and
he is now the enemy.
This is the epitome of how Trump works, but
it is also how the MAGA people work.
You're either uniquely good or uniquely bad.
You're either the absolute best person in
the world or someone who should be ostracized
and maybe even imprisoned.
If Donald Trump really doesn't like you and
all along, whatever your opinion is of Elon
Musk, Elon Musk's behavior was his typical
sort of self-centered, whatever it was I called
it yesterday, it's sort of sort of like a
self-centered prioritization of his own interests
at the end of the day.
And we've seen this with Trump before, and
we've seen this with the Trump people, oh,
this person is now bad.
He's on some kind of naughty list.
And it is absolutely childish.
It's extraordinarily pathetic.
And by the way, for someone who said, I'm
going to be a great president because I'm
going to pick the right people to work with.
It's incredible how poor Trump's judgment
has been selecting all sorts of people for
his staff who he ultimately has to fire or
demand resignations from, and then says they
were terrible people all along.
They were incompetent.
They were given too much responsibility.
Well, who gave them that responsibility?
It was Donald Trump.
None of Musk's views have changed.
Whatever they are and whatever you believe
them to be, they haven't changed.
What's changed is that Donald Trump started
making specific claims about things Elon Musk
told them, and Musk says, I didn't say those
things.
And now Trump ends up like a little kid spending
his afternoon on truth social attacking Elon
Musk.
Stunning, stunning stuff
and humiliating.